mauvaise qualité de l'air prend parfois
des proportions dangereuses pour la
santé tout cela a bien sûr un coût et
frédéric à la source de cette pollution
il ya des particules invisibles qui sont
toxiques
oui on les appelle voilà les pm 2,5
seulement un peu savant ce sont des
micro particules qui sont en suspension
dans l'air et qui parviennent à se loger
dans les alvéoles des poumons avec
évidemment le danger que cela représente
alors c'est notamment sa qui constitue
le smog alors c'est quoi la norme qui
est acceptable
en fait c'est seulement 2,25 la limite
pour la santé des plus vulnérables c'est
on le disait dans le reportage de pékin
on est à plus de 600 donc imaginé un
petit peu la catastrophe on appris
aujourd'hui de cartes en temps réel en
fait des qualités de l'air à travers le
monde et voici ce que ça donne quand
sévère on est dans la norme
quand c'est jaune ça commençait de
problématique pour les plus vulnérables
et plus on va dans le rouge dans le
pourpre dans le mobile violet là on
atteint vraiment des sommets qui sont
inacceptables pour la santé humaine
regardez par exemple new delhi en fait
qui est beaucoup plus on va dire pollué
que pékin on arrive aujourd'hui à une
qualité de l'air très mauvaise donc avec
un indice de 219 je rappelle la norme
c'est 25 et regarder dans cette ville de
la thaïlande 893 imaginé pour les
personnes âgées et pour les asthmatiques
et les enfants c'est une catastrophe
et où est ce que se situe le canada dans
ce degré de pollution alors si on prend
l'exemple de montréal chaque année bon
an mal an on a environ soixantaine
d'épisodes de smog avec parfois des
sommets qui ont été atteint environ 120
donc on est à peu près à quatre et demi
fois le taux qui est acceptable
aujourd'hui montréal on le voit on était
à 68 bon séjourne donc ces modérés
si on va du côté de toronto là la
qualité était meilleur on est vraiment
juste au dessus de la norme et enfin
dans la grande région de vancouver là on
à thenay on était vraiment en même en
bas de la norme c'est quand même pas mal
vers la ville verte
les voilà évidemment tout ça est au
coeur des discussions à paris parce que
il ya des coups à cette mauvaise qualité
de l'air ça coûte évidemment très cher
et regardez-les oms a évalué les décès à
travers le monde à plus de 3 millions de
décès causés par la mauvaise qualité de
l'air alors quand on regarde par exemple
ce que ça veut dire pour le canada
l'association médicale canadienne évalué
le nombre de décès prématurés à 21
milles
la mauvaise qualité de l'air ça veut
dire 92000 hospitalisation 620 mille
visites de médecins le coup de 8
milliards de dollars est en fait un mot
pour terminer céline avec la situation à
montréal où les autorités de santé
publique ont évalué la mauvaise qualité
de l'air elle contribue à 15 cents décès
par an le coût total au québec plus de 2
milliards
donc il faut il voir négligeable du tout
merci vous en prie